[Musique]
la 28e édition de la finale
départementale du parcours sportif
sapeurs pompiers s'est déroulée ce
mercredi 17 mai sur le stade nelson
mandela à sainte marie une compétition
qui a réuni plus de 350 participants
venus des quatre coins de l'île
alors c'est une compétition annuelle
organisée dans chaque 10 qui a pour but
mon physique et technique le cas cela ça
partait alors nous avons six épreuves
des sports athlétiques la vitesse sans
hâte de me font qui est le 1000 m le
saut en hauteur lancer de poids et deux
épreuves purement aubry pied il s'agit
du fabec corner de parcours sportif
accompli une compétition qui a pour but
de favoriser l'entraînement physique et
technique des pompiers mais aussi leur
capacité à travailler en équipe
le costaud que la salvetat vrai
et cette journée aujourd'hui à on
entrera l'heure les comptes et veut
démontrer que par leurs fédérations de
la motivation des arrêts
au service d'une population ils ont
vraiment travaillé dans ce sens avec des
parlementaires notamment qu' avant
l'heure
lens et de poires les 100 mètres ou
encore saut en hauteur un enchaînement
de gestes issus de techniques
opérationnelles qui crée le lien entre
l'entraînement et le terrain on en
partie que cette journée noire
personnellement c'est uniquement pour le
plaisir pas le plaisir c'est souffrir
souffrir très attention
due à l'enchaînement où tous les
activités les ateliers sont proposés au
parcours sportif savoir combien
prochaine vous entraînez plus aguerris
l'essentiel est de participer
les meilleurs athlètes iront défendre
les couleurs du 19 7 4 lors de la finale
nationale le 24 juin prochain à obernai
en alsace
[Musique]